be sure to check out Rob plays there you
can hang out with me while we play video
games and talk about life stuff
so what I want to do here is run over
the events of green arrow rebirth and
what I'm hoping is that at the end of
all this you'll understand exactly what
it is at DC is doing with regards to the
DC rebirth concept and bridging the gap
between the new 52 and pre new 52
continuities so as we discussed in my
rundown video of DC rebirth unlike
common belief which held that the
initiative was designed as a reboot
instead because so many fans had
continued their reading experience from
the pre new 52 continuity into the start
of the new 52 proper with the various
characters and stories he had grown
accustomed to largely being thrown away
in favor of a fresh start on the whole
public outcry and decreased sales led to
the launch of DC rebirth as a means to
provide a best of both worlds scenario
to this end green arrow stands as one of
the best examples of this ideology and
the intention of DC written by Benjamin
Percy with art from autosh wit the
beauty of Green Arrow issue number one
comes in the fact that we don't really
need to know anything about its
character however to provide a bit of
meat and potatoes to our discussion I
want to jump back a bit to some of the
changes made between the relationship
between Black Canary and Green Arrow
prior to and during the new 52 so like
most of all DC's titles - Batman and
Green Lantern Green Arrow was rebooted
in its entirety with issue number one
under the control of JK Kroll with
Oliver's relationships and past
completely ignored taking a look at his
stories prior to the new 52 Oliver
Queen's history was one of the richest
and DCs
including the 1961 to 1983 run of Neal
Adams and Dennis O'Neil my grell's
post-crisis miniseries longbow hunters
as well as the subsequent 80 issue run
and Kevin Smith's 10 issue story quiver
all of which came together to create
hallmarks of Oliver's character
including the struggle of realizing a
sidekick was addicted to heroin the
roadtrip adventures of himself and Hal
Jordan and the internal struggles of
being extremely wealthy while operating
as a vigilante trying to fight on behalf
of the poor and destitute as a result
even if Oliver Queen wasn't a character
fans could directly relate to by way of
their own lives his snappy comments in
quick wit created a perfect storm of
sarcasm and seriousness which was not
often found with in DC's larger universe
however when the new 52 was launched
with DC
maybe keep from creating what had
already been done crawls early stories
in the first three issues established
that Oliver Queen lived in Seattle he
had formed Q core as a division within
the larger Queen industries releasing
technologies that promoted the company's
financial growth while also finding
Oliver's life as green arrow in addition
to removing his friendship with Hal
Jordan his relationship to black Canary
and Roy Harper's heroin addiction
instead the run of Kroll and the
subsequent stories from Keith Giffen Dan
Jergens and Anderson T focused heavily
on bringing the series closer to the
show a change which was neither embraced
nor celebrated by critics or fans
instead the stories were met with near
universal hatred from long term readers
who continued to view the series as a
deviation from the source material they
enjoyed only finding reprieve in the
introductions of Felicity Smoak and John
Diggle as chemical counterparts to their
television characters under the writing
of Andrew Kreisberg and bin Sokolowski
that said with DC Reaper serving to
bridge the gap and maintain the universe
enjoy by existing readers but reach back
to concepts in joy by older readers
Green Arrow number one brings us this
goal in relation to Oliver Queen
including the return of the goatee
moving away from emphasis on the cuecore
the story itself focuses on the return
of Black Canary as a character who
debuted in 1947 with flash comics issue
number 87 as part of the earth 2
universe while her early stories
centered on operating as a sidekick to
the flash family only stepping into her
own in the post-crisis on Infinite
Earths continuity one of the most well
known aspects of Green Arrow's history
was his relationship with Black Canary
to sidetrack here originally meeting in
the Justice Society and Justice League
crossover with Justice League issue
number 21 in 1963 the history between
Black Canary and Oliver Queen was
actually a bit confusing because this
time period in her character's history
had her as the only Black Canary the
romance between herself and Oliver was
never in question however following
Jerry Conway's 1978 secret origins of
super villains because Black Canary was
originally a villain her origin was
detailed in this book establishing a
definitive date of birth and age for her
character as a result d c-- came to the
conclusion that a suspension of
disbelief
wouldn't apply to Black Canary due to
the fact that unlike the rest of
Marvel's lineup fans could not assume
that her escapades took place within a
confined time frame a link to the fact
see continue to include dates of
reference and major events and some of
the time 1983 had come around in the
years leading up to crisis on Infinite
Earths DC introduced a second version of
black canary named Dinah Laurel Lance
who was offered as the daughter of the
original black canary known as Dinah
Drake Lance expanding on this idea and
saying that Laurel had grown up watching
her mother fight alongside the heroes of
the Justice Society on earth - and
looked a follow in her footsteps
eventually adopted a monitor following
her mother's retirement where this was
an understandable idea for a short time
in 1986 following crisis on Infinite
Earths as far as I've been able to tell
and so on he might be able to correct me
if I'm wrong cooler heads prevailed and
the history of Dinah Laurel Lance
remained intact keeping her as the
daughter of Dinah Drake Lance and
transforming the Black Canary concept
into a mantle that was passed down from
mother to daughter as a result the
post-crisis relationship of Green Arrow
and Black Canary
experienced a series of waxes and wanes
focusing heavily on the struggles of the
two as much as it focused on the
light-hearted elements referencing back
to Mike grell's longbow hunters with
Green Arrow taking up residence in
Seattle as opposed to Star City the
original miniseries focus on the torture
and presumed sexual assault of Black
Canary by a mobster destroying her
ability to use the canary cry as well as
her ability to trust men beyond Oliver
in addition to this since the miniseries
was released as part of DC's vertigo
imprint and was designed for mature
audiences the themes of the miniseries
including Oliver's willingness to murder
were carried over to the launch of Mike
roles at 80 issue run which was also
part of vertigo continuing the adult
oriented concepts and maintaining
Oliver's ruthlessness however at the
conclusion of Grylls run going forward
Green Arrow was thrown back into DC's
official lineup removing the
adult-oriented themes and focusing
heavily on his personal life in Seattle
and his relationship with Black Canary
coming out of the events leading up to
and following Infinite Crisis with Judd
Winick taking over the position as
writer following several substitutes
after the departure of Mike Grell
whatever was due to practicality or
fandom and Winnick elevated the
relationship of Black Canary and Green
Arrow from dating to marriage as a
result the Green Arrow title was
canceled and relaunched as Green Arrow
Black Canary focusing entirely on the
duo as a husband-and-wife superhero team
but facing their own personal struggles
including the kidnapping of connor hawke
the son of oliver from a previous
marriage a crazy woman who is obsessed
with Oliver and the normal trials and
tribulations of marriage leading into
the rise and fall story arc with a
prelude storyline cry for justice seeing
the second iteration of the villain
Prometheus laying waste to Star City
after his murder at the hands of Oliver
Green Arrow took to tracking down and
eliminating all villains who allied
themselves with Prometheus as well as
Barry Allen Hal Jordan and Black Canary
attempting to stop Oliver leading to a
battle between the four heroes with
Oliver coming out on top and subduing
his wife the marriage between the two
was effectively annulled with Black
Canary divorcing her husband and the two
going their own separate ways that said
when the new 52 was started Dinah
Lance's history was retconned entirely
removing her relationship to Oliver and
instead replacing it with a veritable
mess depicting her as a member of Team
seven which was composed of various
individuals from different military
agencies birds of prey which functioned
as a joint venture between Dinah and
Barbara Gordon as well as a small stint
as a rock star none of which ever
touched on or hinted at the idea of a
romance between herself and Oliver Queen
and so instead of simply forces it to
together the writing of Benjamin Percy
gives us an organic transition and that
with Dinah having operated as a
vigilante in her own right her
adventures had let her into contact with
Oliver under the assumption that she was
kidnapping a child discarding her rags
in revealing herself as Dinah after
taking the child back Oliver's home and
providing him with a bath the discussion
between the two is a throwback to their
first encounter at her initial dislike
of Oliver were the discussion between
the two focuses on Oliver's extravagant
wealth contradicting his stance of
fighting for the poor the depiction of
Dinah as she's seen here returns us to
the days before the new 52 and that she
and Oliver complemented one another
almost perfectly with Dinah being
headstrong and stubborn while Oliver was
relatively easy going in addition to
this with a child being homeless and
informing both Green Arrow and black
Canary that his home resides within a
homeless encampment referred to as the
jungle and that his mother was kidnapped
their journey continues to see the two
of them bicker but also reveals that the
young boy and the various others
residing within the jungle are being
taken prisoner by people they refer to
as the underground men who in turn take
their victims for auctioning
to various individuals including the
court of owls from Gotham now because
the emphasis of this story was more
about bringing Black Canary and Oliver
together again the undercurrent stands
as the start of an ongoing story arc
likely centering on Oliver's attempts to
locate and destroy the human trafficking
ring
to this end Benjamin Percy actually
wraps things up pretty fast
by having both Oliver and Dinah kill the
various underground men and send a
message to their leader informing him
that Oliver intends to destroy both him
and his life and so with the story
coming to its conclusion where Dinah had
initially operated under the belief that
these stories of Oliver's rudeness and
immature and nature were true the
pairing of the two comes together by way
of Dinah realizing that Oliver had no
problems taking both Dinah and the boy
to his apartment and revealing his
identity if it meant that the boy would
be saved as a result but to officially
appear to come together setting the
stage for the future of DC rebirth
within the confines of the Green Arrow
title with that being said we're going
to bring this video to an end I hope you
guys enjoyed it and let me know how you
guys feel about the DC we birth event
because I read all the titles that came
out today and they were amazing and I
will catch you guys later peace